[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are exploring the
question is it ever okay to kill someone
Wow yep getting real and if so are we
ready willing and able to do it yes and
we're going to beat yeah I said yes I
was
I wasn't saying yes like I'm ready to
kill somebody no spoilers I'm you're
saying yes that is what we're talking
about we're talking about ethical
conundrums that's a great word conundrum
dilemmas conundrums and some classic
some maybe that you've never considered
before so putting ourselves into a
situation where we have to make a
decision that may result in someone's
death and how do we go about navigating
that ethically mmm and comedic Lee of
course you know there's something I've
been wanting to share and I think this
is the perfect place to share it
something listen to me dude this is a
safe space for you thank you the round
table of dim lighting is a safe space
well I've been wanting to tell you about
this thing that happened to me and I do
think I can frame it as an ethical
dilemma well didn't you read it it's
it's for me should I have taken action
oh or for the person who did it to me
was it right for them to do it well or
wrong or I think third option was it
just creepy weird odd or uncalled for
okay now I will say up top this is a
massage story hook I mean if you had to
think about that one thing like the
through line of ear biscuits I don't
know I don't know how you think of ear
biscuits dear your biscuit ear
god bless their beloved ooh she's
talking about massages but we do talk
about massages a lot yeah
okay hopefully you've had your first
massage really this is all just a a plan
to get you if you've never been because
I know you saj you thought about
massages last last episode I did
yeah yeah that's why you were man
massage yeah well I will say well I
won't say I wasn't about to say
something I ain't gonna say because
anything you wanted the sake of safe
space a space yeah so I went in for a
massage and you know the place that I go
to ever since
the pregnant woman had the baby she
never came back and she was amazing
she's massaging that baby she was there
that baby's getting all the massage she
was like the best masseuse I've ever had
if she was like full plump pregnant
interesting and I don't know your
masseuse is pregnant and my trainer was
pregnant yeah my like fitness trainer
was pregnant it did she have the baby
she's like do anything any day now
well she'll never come back probably I'm
gonna betray that baby though you can
come back from having a baby I'm not
saying you can't go she's planning on it
oh she's planning on it she's got like
it she's got it all planned out yet I
thought my masseuse did too but then
it's been it's been almost a year now
and she's not you see not coming back I
think she moved maybe she got a new
maybe shot about the baby new book at a
new vocation well she was perfect at
this it was her gifting hmm um maybe
she's needing so now it's kind of like a
bakery it's kind of a crapshoot
when I go there I'm like I want a deep
tissue massage I want someone who can do
that and I'll lay down like normal we
can what face up face without they tell
you to start face down yeah I know and
then and then halfway through you roll
over and you face up right yep there's
nothing to do with this I'm face down I
got my head into the doughnut and I'm
starting to get this massage in the
backe area and everything's fine I'm
like I'm you know I'm evaluating is this
gonna be a good massage and I'm like it
could be could be more it could be more
pressure so you get that ask for more
pressure but then the pressure increase
a little bit and as the as the hands
move up around the shoulders I start to
notice that the hands are traveling and
kind of a unexpected there's an
unexpected quality to the travelling of
the hands and I just I could
put my finger on it travel like oh the
way that my hands are moving the way
that the hands are moving on my back and
then as the hey let's get a hand from
two different people or what do you mean
I could I can't tell you but they're
moving together thing is in sequence no
it was just a weird feeling I'm
interested in was anything and then as
the hands get up around my shoulder area
you realize it starts to feel this it
the feeling is not any different than
how it's been feeling and only slightly
different than a normal massage but then
all of a sudden I hear this weird noise
like a suction kind of a noise and it's
like and then I realized that the that
the skin on the hands are like sticking
to my body a little bit like like
spider-man yeah it was like spider it
was yes spider-man's giving you so it's
like spider-man but I was a skyscraper
and Spiderman was given the building of
massaging it was me and then she gets
into it a little bit more and I hear
some popping and some stretching this
masseuse has a latex glove okay see okay
all right now what am i and what's our
real latex gloves we'll still slide at
it with massage oil
yeah well massage right that's why I
couldn't tell it first but then when
they got right up there by my ears based
on the sound I could tell it was latex
skin it was gloves missing then I'm like
what is going on did you think this
woman does this for everyone or she
judged you this is definitely a Glover
is definitely a girl ever
I have scabies we what we went to a
great school with a girl whose last name
was Glover remember that I wonder where
that originated from like the first
Glover were they people who made gloves
almost
purely yet right latex gloves for
masseuses yeah and at this point I'm
like I'm whether it's just a good lover
and it was shortened I didn't want I'll
just tell you that I decided not to say
anything but I was trying to figure out
am I gonna say something like what
gloves huh at a certain yeah well those
gloves are at your hands really cold
yeah blue
he's the skin coming off your hands with
a blue I didn't look my my hands weren't
my feet I just said my eyes my hands my
feet yeah my face was in the donut right
it's all speculation I think so could be
if it was hands if it was a fabulous
massage it probably would have overcome
the fact that there was a latex involved
but yeah I started thinking but it was
just an average massage so I think that
made it a little worse but this isn't
make it weird did not make it horrible
it made it weird and I'm thinking yeah
is it me
is there something oh it's weird is it
or is it her I think it's weird I know
the place that you go right and it's
yeah it's a change the chain that's like
known and respected it's not some seedy
place no I assume there's some sort of
like contract that you had to like sign
is like eight or nine masseuses they're
probably all trained under the same
regimen but I think part of that love is
weird if you're gonna elect to wear
gloves and if it's not about you say it
then maybe it's about her maybe it's I
wear gloves because doing this so long
as me my hands really rough and you know
your hands dry out and then it makes for
a unpleasant experience for the person
getting a massage if your hands are like
I had a massage I seriously doubt that's
the reason I had a massage one time for
me from a from a man actually a rough
hanging man he had rough hands and it
almost felt like I was getting scratched
if certain parts of his hands went along
my surface okay I understand that that
can happen but I assume that I do think
that that could is its a hygiene thing I
think this person is like or if they
have I don't open wounds ER I don't like
to touch I don't like to touch people's
skin
I'm sorry I'm in the wrong career I mean
if you uh here we are if you go in the
room and you're like alright let's do
this and you see the person they got a
lot of bacne or like open wounds on the
back first of all don't go to a masseuse
just let yourself heal brother I think I
respect the fact that they could choose
to put on gloves but I don't it wasn't
me I got I got nothing at the time at
least that's gonna make them make them
pause but so I think it has to do
something like that and I again it I
just felt like you need to say something
I just wanna let you know I'm gonna be
wearing latex gloves but I do this a lot
and I do not um I can confidently say
it's not gonna compromise your
experience yeah but if you'd like to
nothing against do you I do this with
everyone yeah the fact that she didn't
say anything I think I think was I I
think we're dealing with an ethical
conundrum and I think she failed but
what was she I murdered what should you
have done you think you should have said
something about it well I think when I
left and I paid and that's when you put
the tip out there you put it in a little
glove and like a dollar just put a glove
as the tip like she's gonna need this
it's not used no the the person at the
counter was like how was it and I was
like fine there were gloves they were
gone but I should have said well I was a
little taken aback by the fact that
there were gloves involved like well I
mean what was this gonna turn into some
sort of like exam I think you could say
that next time now if you go back I
haven't been back since then I haven't
gotten a massage since the latex glove
massage how long ago and for the record
I there was not an exam involved before
a few minutes there I didn't know right
how long ago was this it could have been
an internal massage yeah that's familiar
this has been it's been three months man
well you missed your massage hasn't had
a massage in three months because of the
gloves go somewhere else
or call and say hey there was this glove
situation last time I was there and I
want to know is that still happening and
maybe I need somebody who doesn't wear
gloves yeah I've had a lot of people who
trying to find I'm you're trying to find
your replacement for the lady that is
now massaging the base
actually I'm not going to this place
anymore because they're always booked up
like yeah you know how my schedule is
man I wake up that more on my today I I
have a window time I could probably get
a massage they never can let me get me
in there you know yeah and I think I
might need to call me like listen can I
get a massage today I know it's
last-minute but I'm willing to take the
latex lady like that's me that may be
the world I'm living in now yeah I'm
happy you should go on I'm not happy go
look at the Yelp reviews and see if
anybody's talked about the gloves
because it may have three months later
would you have stopped the moment like
11 minutes into the massage no I didn't
in fact even when someone tells me okay
I'm gonna go what what kind of pressure
would you like and I say hard and then I
say I'll tell you I'll tell you if it's
too much you don't and then i however
during my Palm Springs massage it got to
a point where I thought I was going to I
was beginning to whimper and thought
that I may begin weeping and at that
point I was like doing dance I did say
that and he let up a little bit he was
it was right he was squeezing this
muscle right here in the shoulder like
that band yeah he was like getting his
fingers under it and around it oh wow it
felt so good and the wrong and the right
ways bad and the right ways I don't know
but yeah I've had to tell him to let out
cuz I was I'm gonna start crying I don't
want to do that but it takes a lot for
me to tell you to stop so I'm definitely
if rubber gloves I would say nothing if
she would have done that to me really
well that he's much weirder to say
something about the gloves like she
touches you and you hear something and
then like he like you head up and turn
around like oh you got gloves on huh she
probably loved him okay well we have
more both failed at that more difficult
we've got more difficult ethical
conundrums that we'll be getting to but
first we do want to let you know that
you can pick up links shirt it's got
cotton candy Randy on it it's tie-dye it
looks a little evil he's busting out of
it
not link but cotton candy Randy it's
sweet check it out it says hi daddy's on
it it's available along with many other
things including these mugs at mythical
dot store go to mythical dies store just
to look at the pictures and for no other
reason yeah just have fun last time you
surfed the web yeah you want some
you're not the lands anywhere you're not
to commit to anything just surf but but
word of advice wear your latex gloves
wear glove wear a glove and go over
there when's the last time you use the
term surfing the web and you weren't
being ironic I can't recall it's been a
long time right yeah it's been longer
than my massage yeah I go more than
three months right so there you have it
yeah mythical dust or you boys so we
actually this was the reason for this
episode was we got a question when we
asked you guys to ask us anything a guy
named John the real John dub on Twitter
asked us he said I'd love to hear you
guys discuss the trolley problem okay
and so that guide us it gave us the idea
well what if we did a whole episode
where we just went through some
different ethical conundrums starting
with what I think is most people
probably heard of this may not know
specifically what the specifics are but
you've heard of the trolley problem
maybe give a quick summary though yeah
well I'm just gonna I'm gonna read I'm
gonna read it you see a runaway trolley
let's just say it's a train well but I
think the track see the tracks
okay trolleys the key here is they get
there's tracks involved you see a
runaway trolley moving toward five tied
up or otherwise incapacitated
incapacitated people lying on the tracks
you're standing next to a lever or a
lever whatever you prefer that controls
a switch if you pull the lever the
trolley will be redirected onto a
sidetrack and the five people on the
main track will be saved however there
is a single person lying on the side
track you have two options do nothing
and allow the trolley to kill the five
people on the main track or to pull the
lever diverting the trolley onto the
side track where it will kill one person
which is the more ethical option now on
its face you may have a knee-jerk
reaction and think that you know what
your answer would be but the reason that
this has been considered a difficult
ethical conundrum or just an ethical
conundrum is because there's an active
choice being made to kill someone that
you are responsible for versus whereas
Hassim choice just to sit there and let
some yeah happen in other words you you
you didn't you weren't if you were all
if I were if you weren't present like if
you weren't present and this situation
just happened in the universe somewhere
you wouldn't be morally culpable for any
thing that happened but because you're
there and now you have the option to
pull the lever that's what makes it
that's what makes it a difficult
situation now this the trolley problem
has been used or referenced quite a bit
as we as people are trying to program
autonomous vehicles so self-driving cars
are being given basically programs to be
able to make these kinds of decisions
and interestingly most people who both
most ethicists are most engineers who
looked at this I've said that the
trolley problem is not a great example
of something that an ultimate vehicle
needs to navigate because it's so binary
because it had basically autonomous
vehicles do not enter situations where
it's like one person or five people like
that's very uncommon they're more often
it's there is a range of possibilities
and even within those binary
possibilities there's a there's a bunch
of different outcomes that could happen
and so it's actually way more complex
than just giving it some trolley problem
program or however you would go about
programming a car so but having said all
that what would you let's just say this
is the situation not typically this
doesn't happen people don't get tied to
railroad tracks outside of cartoons
usually or old westerns but let's just
say I didn't think masseuses used latex
right so let's just say you're in this
situation what would you do I feel like
I would pull the lever because I feel
like not doing anything is is a
you know that's still an it's an act of
omission you know well the first thing
that would happen to me is if I was in
this situation that would be like oh
crap
I am literally in the trolley problem
right now I'm like what how did I get
here literally this is happening there's
five people on this track and there's
one person on this track I'm like I'm
right next to the lever that's that's
funny but no you wouldn't I mean here's
the here's an interesting side note in
Michael Stevens series on what was
YouTube read at the time YouTube premium
which who knows what it's going to
become YouTube super super Miam super
super super time nothing right it's just
gonna be nothing some point yeah because
you just be in front of the pay right I
hope buddy system moves in front of the
paywall
yeah we don't know we don't know if
that's a boil so you may know his
channel as Vsauce but he had a series
called mind filled with a deep mind with
addy and he actually set up like a it
was like an elaborate prank people
thought that oh yeah where they were
literally lured into this trailer and
allowed to like take a look at the the
track switching mechanism then the guy
who was in charge of it had to like you
know go to the bathroom their bathroom
or something and then at that moment
looking through the windows or on on the
on the monitors this is okay trains
gonna kill five people or just one
person over here and then they could
either pull the lever or not and I mean
they had they gave it like psychiatric
evaluations to these blind sighted
people beforehand in order to like make
sure they weren't gonna send someone
into like a catatonic state or soft
right yeah and even though they did that
it in and of itself became like
ethically questionable and Michael had a
lot of difficulty submitting people to
the trolley problem was an ethical
dilemma yeah they went through with it
but man it's fascinating because people
were freaking out
you know as you would imagine this is
not a normal you know it's just like I
mean we typically don't have unless
you're a doctor YouTube
we don't have people's lives in your
hands only they unusual situation for
most people I felt horrible for the
people because I mean I don't know do
you remember those people yes Dee like I
mean that I mean they only showed it's
not like a legitimate sample size they I
don't know how they chose who they put
into the edit but everything happened
like somebody ran out somebody broke
down somebody switched the tracks
somebody didn't you know it's like it
all happened no we they didn't have any
statistics they didn't do like it wasn't
like a study it was just a no we pulled
it we pulled the the with the staff here
right so do you did what you didn't yeah
and Kiko says there's like twelve or
fourteen mythical team members who were
okay but what's your answer I mean you
think you HOT
I would definitely pull the lever to
kill the one person you would kill put
one person in in one sense of the word
but you would save I five lives I don't
see a lot of difference because I'm
there and I have the option and my
inaction will result in the death of
five people I don't the the whole thing
about what one is passive and when it's
active in that scenario because it's so
simple and so clean and also I don't
know the people so I don't have it that
you can complicate the trolley problem
which we'll do in a second but an
uncomplicated five six strangers in that
scenario I'm pulling the lever no
questions asked with with little to no
regret it's like you don't know how
brother I'd rather like illogical
ramifications that will be would either
way well of course I'm just saying that
I would make the decision without regret
I'm not saying I wouldn't suffer from
the consequences of having killed
somebody I'll also say that in the good
place they had this entire scene which
was like the trolley problem as you said
it was funny have you seen that the
movie the dawn wall no so you watch free
solo yes Alex Honnold there's another
movie on Netflix
it's another dock called the dawn wall
and it's about a climber it's about
these guys who one guy in particular
who was trying to do the most difficult
face the dawn wall of Half Dome is that
it it's the most difficult climb in the
entire world no one's ever done it now
he's not free soloing he's tied in and
it takes law and they camp up there and
it takes a long time but it's like an
impossible route that guy has an
incredible story and when he was like 19
or 20 years old they went he did
trolleys no they went into it was like
the year 2000 and they went into
somewhere and like who's becca Stan or
someplace like that to do some crazy
climbing and this is like back when
there were sort of the precursors to
al-qaeda and Isis and stuff and there
was some like Islamic fighter dudes who
kidnapped them and shot one of the
people like so killed one of the dudes
so they knew that these guys were
serious but then they were like going in
circles long story short they this guy
one fighter like one-armed fighter ends
up going up this mountain with like
three of them and so they start talking
to each other about how they just need
to push this guy off the cliff and kill
him and they're talking in English
because he can't understand him and the
dude pushes the Gulf the cliff really
yeah just save hit him and himself and
his friends and they it was a huge news
thing like when he came back like he was
on The Today Show and Good Morning
America they were like so you were over
there and you pushed this guy off the
cliff anyway so similar it's a similar
thing like I'm gonna save my friends of
course in that situation this guy has
already demonstrated that he can and
probably will kill you he's in the
Restall he's starting out in the wrong
so it's a little bit different but
anyway I just made me think I predict I
recommend that movie that's not my wreck
I have another wreck but I do recommend
it I predict that mythical team members
are gonna agree with us yeah yeah yeah I
think this one's pretty pretty
straightforward okay so option option 2
is pull the lever majority the majority
of people did say they would pull the
lever but Lucas Kevin Nick and paisley
said they wouldn't wow that's
wow that's an interesting group there's
a weird what do those guys have in
common they don't have any backbone
apparently I can't take action I don't
know there's no how to I I they're not
here - Dave and Matthew Kiko Kristen
chase Kaitlyn Aubree Casey and Bethany
they'd all pull the lever okay well
you're all right now here's what I'll
say the trolley problem wasn't a hundred
percent though trolley problem in my
mind isn't isn't that difficult of a
conundrum but let's complicate it a
little right okay
this is basically hinging on the same
principle of the trolley problem but
more complex situation you are a doctor
at a top Hospital I don't know what has
to be a top Hospital you have six
gravely ill patients five of whom are in
urgent need of organ transplants okay
you can't help them though because there
are no available organs that can be used
to save their lives the sixth patient
however will die without a particular
medicine if he or she dies you will be
able to save the other five patients by
using the organs of patient six who is
an organ donor what do you do now let me
just say say a couple of things before
the smartasses in the comments start
pointing things up I understand this is
not how organ transplants work you gotta
you can't just put take something out of
somebody and put it into somebody else
there's like they have to be matches and
situations like that also also they're
wrong really comments on podcast also
there well when this goes to youtube
there also there are legal like let's
just say you're not working within a
legal system because there are actually
laws like you can't what in other words
if you're at least if you're in the
United States you can't with her you
can't kill someone or let someone die
just to give organs to someone else you
can't do that that's against the law
so in our laws but let's just say that
this is the situation like this person
will save all five people no questions
asked
they're a match and there are no laws
you're not gonna be prosecuted for your
decision but I do think the fact that
there are laws which dictates the
ethics for us I do think that that's
revealing right because I guess it's it
to boil it down it's like do no harm do
not actively hurt somebody even if that
means saving five times as many people
I think the trolley problem in its in
it's just pure necessity shal
presentation isn't it is an easy
situation is an easy decision for me
this how what do you think this is a
saint I are you saying this this is the
same principles but I think that there I
think that there are well the trolley
problem or complex it is preventing
having an option to prevent one of two
accidents which you can't prevent both I
guess that's the same here you're like
preventing like the medical demise of
these people it's not like oh man
well a doctor can't do it a doctor is
not allowed to do that but I so but I
actually feel like this is gonna make
you feel differently you're gonna go
back on the trolley problem because of
this I don't know what do you what do
you what would you do well the reason
the trolley problem seems easier to me
is because it is not my job when you're
a doctor you you've got the hip
Hippocratic oath right and and so you
don't get into the situation where
you're weighing patients lives against
one another because that quickly gets
out of hand right but the trolley
problem in its pure form doesn't get out
of hand it's just so it's so simple it's
just like there's five people five
people died or one person dies five
people want somebody's gonna die and the
trains gonna go on either track it just
seems so binary but as soon as you you
you pull back and you get into a little
bit more of a real-life situation like
this I acknowledge it becomes very very
difficult to make a decision
but let's just say you're not you're not
okay you're not going to be a couple
things can be Gary you're not gonna be
prosecuted you know that all those
people are going to be saved and well
it's just not that's you there are you
have to do the right I think the right
thing to do is not to harm the person
you got to try to give this person the
medicine give the one person medicine
and help them and then trust that you
know what other people are gonna die and
maybe the last minute some organs are
gonna swoop in
maybe we'll open a cabinet and it'll be
full of organs whoops forgot about that
organ cabinet well and that's why in the
in real world this is why you've got to
behave exactly the way right because you
don't know what's gonna I don't have all
but not because real world situations
are more complex and things can change
but what if these are the LAT okay okay
what if these are the last six people on
the planet okay these are the last six
people on the planet
well now you can say five or you can
save one is the one to be you and one
person woman you can procreate with
let's just say you're a man and they're
all women I'm not trying to create like
a utopian situation for myself I'm just
I'm just saying that no so you are going
yes the different ethical question I
don't know so I'm saying that like you
you have to repopulate the planet it's
your your job the burden is on you but
you but you just you can do it with five
I didn't mean to walk into this
situation it's not about it's not about
procreation it's just about these are
the last people on the planet if it's
not about procreation
it's not about continuing the species
this is who cares okay no what if you're
all going to die everyone everyone's
infertile but either six people total
are going to continue to live or two
people let's continue let's do the best
you can to the person who's dying the
quickest and if that's given the
medicine given the medicine and then
maybe again maybe somebody just needs
kid need I didn't go and kill him well
situation this and then you go to the
five people and you say like alright
which one of you wants to sacrifice
yourself in order to give your organs to
the other people it's like giving up an
airplane seat yeah it's no different let
it be their decision I would take a poll
that's what I would do I put it back on
them but like I'm just a guy with a
knife you know you guys have the power
okay so you think he would be ethically
okay to tell the person who listened I
can give you this medicine but I want to
want you to know that if you die you'll
save five people you think it's ethical
to tell that person that and now they're
gonna be wracked with guilt the rest of
their life if they take the medicine I
don't think you can do that either I
don't think well that's kind of mean but
it's not wrong it's true I think they
need to have a right okay they need to
have a voice in it let's let's listen
make this even more complex
what if there's one person has the
organs to save a million people that
that can't happen again it's not a real
situation but I'm just I'm saying they
could save a million people that's
amazing well yeah okay yeah just let him
go that's a lot of people a million
people yeah a million people this person
has lots of extra organs like a million
hearts yeah they got all kinds of stuff
like cows that with stomachs yeah is
there a point in which it becomes okay I
think it's a million that's a big nice
round number like half a million because
if you I think half somebody came four
hundred ninety nine thousand nine
hundred ninety nine no but somebody came
they were like you could have saved this
a million people you could have saved a
hundred people you could have saved a
thousand people but you got you this one
guy was better and you know what it
turns out this guy's in and not only
that but he's kind of a jerk what if
what if the guy what if the guy you need
to give the medicine to is 87 years old
yeah I would let it be his decision I'm
still going with that things get even
with the minute and how do you place
worth on some
life it's become worth less as they get
older now we're in the euthanasia
situation hmm what if the what if the
person what if it's a million people but
then the one person who could get the
medicine and get fully well is your wife
or like your child well okay so what
you've essentially done is take the
trolley problem but the one person on
the track is my kid your kid yeah what
do you do now I don't know those five
what if what if it's my three kids and
then over here on the other track are
your two kids well why you laugh who and
who's Scott who's got the lever you I'm
sitting there watching though and whose
kids are gonna die if I don't do
anything i'ma pull that leap we're gonna
both be yanking on that lever I got to
work on my yanking skills well okay
all right you know what I got more kids
than you okay all right you know what
I'm going to skip to that exact question
that's um oh that's an exact question
pretty close your family is vacationing
alone more private stretch of beach with
no lifeguard your daughter I was just
doing that and you're nice okay both
7-hour best friends and eager to get
into the water you caution them to wait
until the water calm some but they defy
you and sneak in anyway you soon hear
screams of distress and find them but
strong current well you got it listen
you may be you may be presented with
this real-life connected me you have to
make a decision put your speedo on and
will you put your big-boy speedo up
you're the only strong swimmer you're
the only swimmer strong enough to save
them but you can only save one at a time
your niece is a very poor swimmer and
likely won't make it much longer your
daughter however is a stronger swimmer
but only has a 50% chance of holding on
long enough for you to come back for her
who do you save first
oh now I have as I read this I've
formulated my answer there's a there is
a 50% chance that you could say both of
them
let's just say that let's not say that
okay in Jimmy this seems easy I gotta
save the one that's a weaker swimmer I
said I have to save my niece and then
hope for the best for my daughter for a
couple of reasons number one my daughter
has a better chance of surviving on her
own my niece doesn't at least as
presented in this situation and you have
to deal with this decision forever and
you have to deal with the people's
opinions about your decision forever and
to be like I sacrifice my own kid to
save yours versus I sacrifice your kid
to save mine is kind of a better legacy
right it's something it's easier to live
with it's not easy to live without your
own kid obviously but I think there's
something has to take into account but
let's just say they're not ones not a
better swimmer let's just say you've got
to save one of them and one of the other
than the other one is going to die and
they're both equal swimmers do you save
your daughter's friend or niece or
whatever or do you save your daughter
it's not like you're swimming out there
and then like a video game there's like
a percent chance of like like their
survival and like data on how well it
will have a swimmer there you're gonna
swim out there you're gonna grab them
off you metadata over people's heads at
all times no I do and then you're gonna
swim out there and you're gonna grab
both of them and you're gonna look for
the best and you're gonna you're gonna
all drown probably I mean I'm sorry but
that's what's gonna happen
like but that's what I would do you'd
grab both of them and drown and that
you're not thinking logically all you're
thinking is I've got to rescue these
girls and you go out there and you grab
them and you try to figure out a way and
like it doesn't happen immediately so
it's like I don't you know I I don't
like I want to talk about this hold up
but this is this is why this it's a
conundrum and you can't just run from
the conundrum it's a swim out into the
middle of is it is this tell the fact
that I don't want to talk about it means
I'm not gonna swim out there at all I
guess I wanna swim out there man I don't
know I've surprised myself before both
of them i watch one of those john key
Onis what would you do
situations
and they were they were trying to figure
out if how people would intervene you
know basically the whole show is about
are you gonna intervene in this
situation but yeah and then there's a
certain actually a smaller percentage
than you would imagine of people who are
like heroes like very like a lot of
people are like when people do something
crazy and save a bunch of people and
they're like I mean anybody would have
done what I did in that situation any no
no no very few people would have done it
actually there's an Indian in it isn't
necessarily the case that the people who
make the decision to run out and put
themselves in harm's way to save someone
are like inherently better people like
morally in every other way they would
like be like very consistently moral and
ethical in other areas of their lives
it's just that they have something in
them that makes them not freeze up like
most people do in those situations and
actually go into action and solve the
problem I don't think that I am I've
never been presented with this situation
but I have a tendency to think that the
most of what would be driving me in that
situation is like I'm gonna feel like
such a jerk if I don't do something but
I don't think the people who act think
that I think they just do it they do it
without they do it without thought
they're doing it before it's too late
yeah just on instinct so what would you
do when you swim out there I noticed you
just tend to be asking the questions and
then you don't really test hey what you
would do well I mean okay I think
realistically what I would do is I like
you said I wouldn't quickly calculate if
I was the only person out there and they
were basically next to each other I
would be like both you guys grab onto me
and I would start trying to swim now
what would probably happen is pretty
quickly I'd realized that I can't swim
in with both of them so I'm right back
to the decision I have to make a
decision I have to let someone go
I could be like okay guys we're not
gonna try to swim in we're just gonna
drift and I would like to be like all
right look everybody calm down
everybody calm down and just breathe in
deeply we're gonna float and we're gonna
wait for it's a lifeguard in the jet ski
to come or the Coast Guard or something
we're just gonna try to float like I'm
not gonna try to save you I'm gonna try
to create a situation where I can
prolong my indecision for as long as
possible so I think practically that's
what I would do but if it was like
legitimately you've got to make a
decision I think I'd have to pick the
one that wasn't my kid well let's just
this is so much fun let's just move on
to another one okay is there isn't there
one related to like if or just me and
you let's not bring children into this
okay well I have a lot much lighter
hearted one okay I thought that was one
about like we're on an island and
there's a cure yep here we go choice for
the Cure so we'll do this one then we'll
do the lighter harder one you and your
friend are stranded on an island
unfortunately you're both fatally ill a
lot of people are just fatally ill
gravely ill in these situations it just
so happens that you have an antibiotic
that can cure your illness sadly enough
there's just enough antibiotic to save
only one person how could you and your
friend choose which one of you will take
the antibiotic do you think the either
person who takes it will or should feel
guilty for the other person dying
although if neither if you take it you
will both die so we both got the thing
and somehow we know that we can't just
divide it up I mean I I first of all I
question that it's like if we're out
there on the island and we're drumming
up this antibiotic yeah we can't keep
poking holes we can't keep poking holes
in the ethical conundrums because you're
right they're not realistic well that's
what's frustrating about them I think
what I would do is well that's what
makes programming autonomous vehicles so
difficult because real-world conundrums
are not this you know switching it's not
just all these little binary decisions
it's it's all in a spectrum I would
suggest that we split the antibiotic and
hope for the best and if
we both die I can live with that that's
really good did you mean her to be that
good well okay I ever took ethics in
Kyle right okay did you know I wanted to
talk about that because interestingly
because we've got engineering degrees
now you actually ended up taking an
intro to film class which was the most
interesting class that either of us took
yeah you decided - as I had to write a
paper and it was horrible how to write a
paper about movies well that sucks
really watch movies make or make movies
but I was I've talked about this I was
talking about this with Jesse there I
was like my college education was so
technical yeah that it is just useless
to me now it's just like I wish oh the
best class I ever took was that future
studies class I took a psychology 101 if
I could go back to college I would just
be like what am i interested in that's
what I want to learn of course I didn't
have to use my degree so that's a
privilege that I have but yeah we never
talked about this we never took an
ethics class okay I didn't even take a
statistics class you got to take that I
would not recommend taking that to
scratch an itch no but it took two of
those i but it's it's very practical
yeah it's very practical
it gets very impractical very quickly
but yeah but we like we didn't talk
about these things in the and they make
better discussion questions than
real-life situations but okay
here's what here's a much since you're
talking about what we would split -
antibiotic okay what if the two of us
have taken up commercial aviation and we
but we're freighter or freighter pilots
okay and so we're like flying Freight
across the country and a big FedEx plane
it's just the two of us planes going
down for some reason there's only one
parachute you would say you would ask me
can I have the parachute and I would say
I'm afraid not
oh gosh why would you already have the
parachute no but I would already have
how do we okay first of all you don't
have it on you think we I'd be halfway
out the door here's the thing is that
you get into the situation and you're in
a panicky situation like that how many
best friends would just start beating
the hell out of each other
to try to end this be like the other
guys gonna die I don't would not do that
we wouldn't do that we would we would
begin that we would begin to try to
evaluate and very quickly not be like
you're taller man no if it was okay if
it was me and probably gonna like hit
the propeller when he was me and my dad
then I think we would be my dad we'd be
like son you take the parachute I'm 75
sacrifice myself for my kid I'll give my
kid a parachute yeah and I'm not just
talking about my kid yeah I would also
do it for my kid I think that it whoever
has the most life ahead of them or
whatever
they they that's a good way to sort of
gauge it right but if it's fun if it's
us even though I are I am taller and a
little bit older which means I will die
first if it's just about natural causes
but we won't be making those kinds of
decisions I think I think from all
intents and purposes we is even we we
each have an even claim to the rest of
our lives so I thought we have to do the
thing I like about the island is that
there's there's you can have days of
negotiation like that's fun okay at
least we're having fun we're like trying
to trying to come up with some kind of
competition trying to figure out I think
it has I think you would do you would do
that thing we did as kids where it'd be
like we'd be like him hauling around in
your front yard he'd be like hey you see
that stop sign way over there first
person to take a rock and hit like the
Oh gets the antibiotic it's the antibody
I wouldn't do that
I think we would say we have to do
something we have to let the fates
decide you'd roll the dice you've gotta
roll the dice and I'll make the dice you
gotta take a nap I'm gonna make the die
so rock paper just take a nap I'm gonna
make the dice I'm not gonna be taking
the antibiotic
I wouldn't really do an ocean water I
don't think we should do
rock-paper-scissors because that's a
competition then somebody feels bad
about their gamesmanship it's like how
do we let the fates make this decision
it's like picking up a palm leaf and
both throwing it up at the same time so
one person is in control in whichever
direction it's pointing that's the
person that gets the antibody flip of a
coin a flip of a coin but it has to be
flipped by us together yeah we're about
to flip it together or we're just like
no link you get to flip the coin then
we're both gonna live with the results
you can't you can't control when lands
and the fates have to say well that's
then that's the comedy because I flipped
the coin and it like goes in a hole goes
under snake hole there snakes on this
island yeah and then we got it like dig
out and I want to live and then we're
like we want to dig out the hole in
order to see but you got to dig it out
such a way to see how it landed so the
snake comes out and bites you and then
I'm like hey man not only do you have
that other illness now you've got you've
been bitten by snake so give me the
antibiotic if we were in the parachute
thing to me that's easy I think again
I'm on the middle ground man I think
what we would do is you're the you're
bigger you'd wear the parachute okay you
want me to hold on to you now and then
I'm gonna I'm gonna latch on to you like
a like a baby monkey I'm gonna put my
legs inside of the straps on my arms
inside in straps and I won't latch on
all you all your joints will dislocate
as soon as I pull the cord man yeah they
want me hold on only you I'm just as
strong as a fine I'll wear the parachute
and you my son to me what would happen
if two people are on one parachute
though I mean I know tandem happens all
the time but it's like a special chute
right no I don't think so yeah we both
you're right though
maybe I mean I have I wear a belt at all
times so I could probably somehow strap
myself in via belt all right take my
jeans off and tie myself inside be naked
but general I don't want you to be Nikki
I have underwear on I don't want you I
want you have clothes on I want to live
man but you're right that is what we
would do but if we're on the island what
what there's no arguments that we be
making
like well I have more kids to support
than either I'd be I'd make that
argument yeah but I don't think that I
don't think that that stands more
immediate family members will be sad to
see me leave than you I you can't you
can't get into I think the only thing
that seems like a fair negotiation
tactic is how much life you have to live
but judging the worth of your current
life kids in yeah it just gets into some
gray areas so what what would you do
about the antibody you would flip a coin
yeah yeah wait for the flip a coin
this is the opening scene of our movie
by the way we're both dying and only one
of us can live we flip a coin it goes
into a snake hole I mean the rest of
movies just digging into that snake hole
it's a short film yes it sure I'm gonna
ask this this one that is a little bit
less of a life-or-death situation we've
actually talked about something like
this every day you commute your commute
back home requires you to exit from a
two-lane road onto a freeway to do so
you must be read it one more energy yeah
I mean it's already boring at least try
to make it sound everyday your commute
back home requires you to exit from a
two-lane road onto a freeway to do so
you must be I'll call them merge in the
right lane but that right lane backs up
for two miles adding 20 minutes to your
daily commute you're tempted to stay in
the left lane
which moves much more quickly and then
right before the freeway on-ramp cut
ahead of the cars that I've been waiting
for the 20 minutes do you cut in we do
this every day
first of all not the way that we go home
we encounter this yep yep so yep I mean
not coming to work but going home I'm
offended by this question because I
think it sets me up to be bad
well we okay so we talk yet I slide in
at the last second you know why because
at the last second there that's when
people they loosen up they think oh they
think oh I'm through with this merge I
can I can take my time I don't have to
be right behind the person in front of
me and they leave
a gap and so nobody loses well well
maybe they put on brakes in one sense
your behavior is creating a longer line
but let your career you're actually
contributing to the problem that you're
avoiding which is not a great ethical
place to be however right I would do the
same thing but I do it based on the
principle that we talked about on your
biscuits before and which is that the
proper way and the way that autonomous
vehicles will merge when they're all
autonomous is they'll do it in the in a
zipper fashion that fold in that's not
what's happening one after another this
is not two lanes coming into one lane
and the thing that we actually do where
it's like you got a freeway and then an
exit to then go on to then go on an
overpass onto another freeway and you
can either be in the far right lane
which backs up your I can be one lane oh
right is that it never is not it's not
losing a lane you're right you're right
it's just you have to you everybody's
got to funnel into someplace you risk
someone not letting you in and then
you're sitting there in the median like
a chump and then you pay the concert
guys I'm willing to pay those consequent
eat I'm this might reveal something
about me that you know but I'm just
being vulnerable I do it and as I'm
doing it
I think to myself you know what a lot of
people are just not comfortable with the
uncertainty and the tension that is
created with getting in at the last
second but you know what I am
comfortable with that so so so all these
people who are who are backed up they
just want to get in and avoid this
situation that I am voluntarily
inserting myself into this chaotic they
don't have like minute decision to take
the risk that's what I'm actually
thinking without even really processing
it even though I know that the reality
is these people are just nice and I'm a
[Laughter]
because only and it would think that
he's actually embracing chaos and these
people are afraid
over here laughing I do you get it you
do that oh you get in the line and well
how do you feel about the people are you
avoiding or devoting chaos you get mad
she said no I'm not having a rough day
I'm just having another day I'm going
home yeah we got I mean but people you
people waiting for us we got kids
waiting for us I think the quite a
secure bunch of single people then under
see anybody is that some of the dog or
whatever I don't have to see Jenna that
corner my the whole time we're doing the
podcast get that judgment that judgment
has the back of my head not to the less
the side of my eye okay so we just
concluded I think the problem the the
real test of that is if everybody did
what we did what would happen and then
you Elaine that is supposed to be like a
65 mile per hour freeway lane becomes an
a second off-ramp lane that ain't how
supposed to be yeah right matter of fact
I encounter we encountered this twice
going home and that's why I don't have
the patience to do that twice to sit in
that long line and just quote mellow out
you're right getting on Buzz both
interchanges is what happens yeah yeah
oh no I think differently about it as
I'm driving today I'll do the same I
will think differently okay one last one
that I think is also practical this is
something that we can't personally
relate to but it actually makes me think
of an idea I recently pitched to my wife
now pitch it to everyone on your on a
dating website is it ever ethical to
make yourself seem younger than you are
you're older you've been single a long
time and you're lonely you're frustrated
that it seems that all the good
potential romantic partners want someone
younger
you think if only they'd give me a
chance they'd see I bring a lot to a
relationship even if I have wrinkles so
you're entering this is very specific so
you're wondering if like many people
your profile should say
you're younger than you are and include
only a distant photo so your age isn't
as a parent what would you do
so let lying about lying about your age
yeah okay that that feels like that's a
situation you can't back out of if the
if you're looking for any more than just
a hookup no I think that's a great way
to start a lasting healthy relationship
but let's just say what do you think
about and again we don't use dating apps
never have that we got married before
any of this was a thing and but people
deceive purposely on their profile they
exaggerate they only show pictures where
they look good right they only show
pictures of their good side or the good
angle or whatever
let me just pitch an idea to you because
this whole this whole process seems very
deceptive and I think that this
technology for this exists I told Jessi
there should be a dating app where the
only picture is you open up the app you
take a picture like you turn the camera
on you do a video of your head like this
all three second you do and then you do
a video like this vertically in
horizontal and then you enter it into a
program that then creates a perfect 3d
model of what you actually look like and
then the person who looks at your
profile there's no swiping or anything
it's it's an augmented reality it's a R
where is it you can like put the camera
up there your phone and you move your
phone around and just like you're
looking at the person in space okay whoa
wait chin o weak chin or like oh well
look like and so you know exactly in the
name of the dating app is shallow that's
my pitch no seriously that's it that's
my pitch anybody wants to invest in this
all it is is a augmented reality
interact a picture of a person's face
literally you don't even know their name
no stats about them you don't know their
age your decision is based completely on
what they actually look like in real
life
it's called shallow listen based on what
you know I'm taking investors based on
what you just told me if you hadn't
already told me about how you drive I
would now know okay
no it's just an idea for a dating app
its authenticity its authentically
shallow presenting yourself but it's
like we're listening actually all about
what kind of look like I got a better
idea what do you think about my idea I
don't like it
I have a better one okay you can use
this on any dating app and I don't need
any investment you you post a picture
you either a split screen or two
pictures and you're like this is me
going out on a date with you
first date look and this is me staying
in like I don't expect to see anybody
like not even going out to get that mail
and it's like he said if you want to get
into like physicality go and take care
of it say this is my this is my spectrum
this is my hottest and you can send it's
my nada so here's the thing and and you
and your people can still deceive within
that because what you do is you set up
one of those what do you call it when
it's a candid shot that's that app
landed
you know you've you know this the word
that people are thoughtful now planned
it however this is what's happened on
Instagram where it's a planned candid
shot uh-huh yeah you're right
so people would be like easy to fake
that look at me in my little PJs this is
when I this is me not going out I look
so gross right but you still see my good
side you know what I'm saying we need to
I want a 3d skin that includes
personality man okay all right all right
maybe maybe we can incorporate the 3d a
art technology into a more comprehensive
dating app that takes into account
things other than physical appearance I
just thought if you if you really want
to just make a decision based on what
somebody looks like because that is a
big part of the initial thing you don't
didn't make a decision of whether or not
you're gonna continue dating based on
that but a lot of its kind of based on
that initially I'm just saying in fact
if you tender or whatever the other ones
are yeah
talk to me let's let's incorporate this
into your app I think you need to create
a tinder account fresh and it this whole
idea of being able to actually see what
somebody looks like because when you get
when you get there and you meet at the
coffee shop you let me you go be swiping
we got hitter you're gonna see every
swipe you can't maintain noggin you
can't maintain your good side this angle
during the whole conversation you can't
do that you can try but eventually
they're gonna see the other side of your
face
and then they've got a deal with deal
with the reality I think it's in other
words I do think [ __ ] logically wrong to
lie about definitely lie about your age
your job any of that stuff but I think
that it's a gray area ethically to lie
about the way you look I mean you want
to put your best foot forward but you
got to drag that other foot along for
the ride you gotta put your bad foot out
there yeah that's right because you're
attached to it quite literally I think
I've learned I don't
sorrow ver simplified I think you know
they're constructs to help think of
things that then in the real world you
either just acting on instinct or
probably choosing the wrong thing you
know to me the biggest ethical premise
that I live by is act quick and
apologize often hmm I should have saved
my niece but I don't know I just
swimming fast and my daughter was right
there sorry
mmm-hmm well tried to put it in context
and don't let don't let your niece
listen to this do you have a nice I
don't have a nice yeah I got nervous I
was almost gonna say I don't have
anything I'm like hold on do I have a
nice I have a half nice okay well I
think we've solved I think we think it's
the thing yeah yeah half sister she's
got daughters
I got a half niece oh yeah you do have
half nieces yeah yeah don't go swimming
with him oh we did go to the beach once
really yeah women mm-hmm
I'm glad they didn't know that you
thought this way about them well I think
the worst thing is it seems like I
forgot that existed before so I
definitely wouldn't say what I didn't
know they were they were around well
I've only only I've only met him one
time I've only met him once
yeah yeah I don't do probably doesn't
mean okay so is it talk talk a lot
apologize most of the time I have do you
have anything else ethical no because I
have I have a wreck
that I had let's move on to
recommendations because it's ethically
explode I'm trying to be good right
that's hard now this actually would have
been a better wreck for our previous
episode about the secret to long-term
marriage
oh okay because I'm making a music wreck
and I'm making a music wreck that's it
there's an interesting story that goes
along with this because I was in the
process of creating my it's business
time program that involves lights we
remember in a certain playlist and let
me just say for those of you who like to
have sound like to have musical
accompaniment to your mail sorting I
think is the term that we use is the
best if you want to see if you if you
enjoy sorting the mail with your
significant other and you'd like to do
that too of soundtrack some kind as I do
as my wife does what I found on on
Spotify Apple what what regardless of
the music service the playlists that
people have come up with for mail
sorting mm-hmm are inadequate and they
don't align with my personal taste it's
just you're like oh this is a good one
everything's going right and then all of
a sudden you're like what why'd you put
this one in there you've ruined it for
us too much conga and so I was like I
have to engineer my own playlist that
fits to my wife and I spy
and I don't want to impotent playlist in
the process of building this playlist I
happened upon an artist I was not
familiar with named Mack Ayers you may
see a y/r is young guy from New York
who's got a couple albums and it's just
this funky soulful it's baby-making
music and the in fact he was called the
king of baby-making music by somebody
like billboard or somebody I mean there
was an article about it you know how
billboard likes to make babies and this
guy is really really incredible now I
added many of his songs to the playlist
I have like a fifty song playlist and I
think max got ten songs on there what if
I that's wishful thinking if I've ever
heard of it fifty song playing I'm not
trying I'm not saying I'm gonna go for
50 songs
it's a shuffle the list you never know
what you're gonna get - some Rihanna on
there that's the ethical conundrum and
so you never know which I want I don't
want to be repeating myself you know in
any way shape or form I just want the
lights to be red every time well I mean
it's weird like special we're dialing in
the color of the lights yeah well
there's a reason that new menus really I
mean try it have you tried it
well do I need to sign up to use your
bedroom or something no you can have one
of my bulbs or you could buy your own
you can reserve a slot in your so I find
this guy very impressed and and Jesse's
very into it oh that's good move on and
you know she's very into the music and
you know and the whole family by the way
I didn't tell the kids why I got to know
this guy the whole family likes the
lights this guy he's got he's got a cool
vibe I didn't say oh it's it's for it's
the reason you're here is the reason we
like in singing that
I follow this guy on Twitter it's like
playing a very white and you're like for
your bar mitzvah I start following Mack
on Twitter he immediately follows me
messages me and says man I'm a mythical
beast he's like I've been I've been a
fan since I was in Middle School he was
like I had the mythical shoes and
everything
what samac mythical beast airs king of
turn off the mad king of baby-making
music is a mythical beast does he have
any children
well he's responsible for a lot he finds
to be paying child support so a lot of
people just because his music is so
effective anyway highly recommend Mac
not just for baby making music just for
good vibes and also because he's a fan
of uh but he's a good guy he's got great
taste and Internet comedy and he's a
talented musician up-and-coming guy
think he's like 22
take a listen follow him on up and buy
me nothing Avery was latest out that's
just what you do in response to hey you
know okay all right okay okay all right
okay all right okay all right got it let
it lay men shout out to Mack reckon
effect there's your wreck hashtag ear
biscuits boy I'm glad you're still here
you know it's like boy you could there's
so many points you could have left like
karma killing nieces I should have seen
the original list like we were doing the
research on this it was like that was
like like some more of it stuff oh I
can't take this it was like no that's
what weeks of greatest I mean the ones
that we didn't talk about that ethical
conundrums floating around on the
internet well and you know what if you
were now right next if you want us to
talk about some more there's a lot of
these available there's a lot more to
talk about we didn't get into some of
the even greedier ones but I'm willing
to go there
let us know let us know if you want to
hear more about this hashtag ear
biscuits alright we'll speak initially
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]